[Música]
una sacerdotisa solitaria se encamina
hacia una cámara subterránea la gente
llena las calles para verla proclamar su
inocencia pero ya ha sido juzgada y
declarada culpable la sentencia será
enterrada viva en la cámara subterránea
hay pan agua leche y aceite tendrá una
lámpara una cama y una manta pero no
saldrá viva en el umbral las
sacerdotisas de una pausa proclama su
inocencia una última vez y entra en la
cámara para nunca más ser vista por el
pueblo romano la sacerdotisa es una de
las seis vestales de roma' cada una
elegida meticulosamente entre las
familias más aristocráticas pero ahora
con su muerte sólo hay cinco y se debe
elegir una nueva sacerdotisa la pequeña
licinia de seis años presenció el
espectáculo sin sospechar que unos días
después sería elegida como la próxima
ves tal su edad ser de una familia
patricia y su aparente buena salud la
hacen mejor candidata ante los ojos
romanos para servir a la diosa best a
sus padres están orgullosos de que haya
elegido a su hija virginia tiene miedo
pero no tiene elección debe servir a la
diosa al menos durante los próximos 30
años durante los primeros 10 años de
servicio y cinia es considerado un
aprendiz aprende a ser una virgen vestal
su tarea principal es mantener encendida
la llama the best a la virgen diosa de
el hogar vesta no tiene una estatua como
otros dioses y diosas romanos en cambio
está representada por la llama que arde
día y noche en su templo que está cerca
del foro en el centro de la ciudad como
todas las sacerdotisas vestales licinia
pasa parte del día de turno observando y
cuidando la llama la llama representa
dos cosas la primera es la continuidad
de roma como potencia mundial para los
romanos si la llama se apagaba la ciudad
estaba en peligro la llama también
simboliza la virginidad de las
sacerdotisas de vesta para los romanos
la virginidad de una vestal significaba
no sólo castidad o virtud espiritual o
física sino también su pureza ritual
ya sabe que nunca debe dejar que se
apague la llama de eso depende su vida
las vidas de sus compañeras vestales y
la salvación de la propia roma listín y
aprende a recolectar agua cada día de
una fuente cercana para limpiar el
templo aprende el 'fast y el calendario
de rituales sagrados y mira a la vestal
superior hacer sacrificios
cuando línea completa su formación tiene
16 años y cinia entiende que su forma de
actuar es un reflejo de la diosa a la
que sirve cuando es su turno de
recolectar el agua mantiene sus ojos
mirando al suelo cuando realiza
sacrificios se concentra intensamente en
la tarea licinia dedica su energía a ser
la mejor sacerdotisa posible le preocupa
que algún día el estado reclame su vida
para protegerse del peligro
licinia podría ser acusada de incesto o
de no ser casta en cualquier momento y
ser sacrificada sin importar si es
culpable o inocente licinia ahora
entiende por qué enterraron viva a su
predecesora
hace 10 años se apagó la llama de vesta
las sacerdotisas sabían que no podían
mantenerlo en secreto el futuro de roma'
dependía de ello fueron a ver al
pontífice máximo y éste abrió una
investigación para descubrir la causa de
la falla alguien intervino y dijo que
una de las vestales ya no era virgen ese
fue el principio del fin
la acusada proclamó su inocencia pero no
bastó fue juzgada y declarada culpable
la muerte de la vestal fue para proteger
la ciudad pero licinia llora por lo que
se ha perdido y por lo que ella sabe
ahora su propio camino estaba cimentado
por la muerte de otra ves tal y su vida
podría acabar fácilmente por algo tan
simple como una llama que se apaga
para conocer más historias sobre las
consecuencias de no respetar las reglas
mira este vídeo sobre el mito griego de
pandora y recuerda suscribirte a nuestro
canal para no perderte ninguna
oportunidad de aprender algo nuevo
ah